did you know the periodic table of
elements aren't just reserved for
science lessons they're in fact all
around us they're in this table in our
clothes and in the snacks these salted
potato crisps are made up of about 13
elements most notably they're sodium and
chlorine from the salt with potassium
and calcium coming from the potato so
cool and uh what happens when we eat
them well the elements like potassium
help with heart health and blood
pressure and calcium is for our bones
and muscle function but don't worry this
doesn't mean you only need to eat Cris
to get these elements they're found in
lots of different foods like this Trax
this is spec with nuts seeds and even
some kale it has 16 elements including
iodine magnesium and some copper and
what's so great about those well iodine
helps your body and brain grow and
magnesium and copper are important for
energy production